[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
now produced by clash of minds
hi martin hi walter how are you i beat
you too
well i'm well how are you i'm fine thank
you that's good clash of minds is there
any difference
from amazing discoveries africa
well same aim same goal
same everything
but it is to bring attention to a clash
of minds exactly so and that's why we've
titled this one also clash of minds
slash of minds we'll talk talk about
some of the things we've spoken about in
the past
and have a look at why this is relevant
for the time in which we are living so
let's open with a word of prayer
how far they in heaven
there's so much happening in the world
and we need some clarities there's a lot
of clashing and of minds going on and we
need your
holy spirit to guide us through all of
this so that we ask now please enlighten
our minds
in jesus name amen
it's a minefield out there martin
and
amidst this quagmire of ideas
somewhere
we have to find the thread of truth
right correct
and once you've found it
then your whole mindset has to change
and the old and the new
will clash
and
like martin luther said right
let the minds clash
but keep the fists down
well let's start right in the beginning
genesis chapter 3 verse 15
and i will put enmity between thee and
the woman
and between thy seed and her seed and it
shall bruise thy head and thou shalt
bruise his heel
martin what sits in the head
the cognitive the making
so
that mindset
that comes from the serpent
will eventually be destroyed yes
so it's very important that we be able
to discern what that mindset is right
correct
you remember the previous what's up
prophet we did it's also interesting
when we go to the king of the north and
south it also has to do with a mindset
and the doctrine of the serpent versus
the doctrine of scripture
here's a quote from selected messages
and it says but satan reached only the
heel
he could not touch the head
at the death of christ satan saw that he
was defeated
he saw that his true character was
clearly revealed before all heaven and
that the heavenly beings and the worlds
that god had created
would be wholly on the side of god
he saw that his prospects of future
influence with them would be entirely
cut off
christ's humanity would demonstrate for
eternal ages the question which settled
the controversy
so here
was a declaration
that the mindset of christ
never changed
it could not be reached could only reach
up to his heel
but the other head would be crushed
martin is also interesting
that the mindset
of the enemy of christ
is also
the mindset of the world
that's it and that's a very very sad
statement that means how much of the
world must be reached with the other
mindset the whole world the whole world
that's also why jesus said you are in
the world but you should not be off the
world yes
james 4 4 says ye adulterers and
adulteresses know ye not that the
friendship of the world is enmity with
god
whosoever therefore will be a friend of
the world is the enemy of god
now modern the world is a big place
so in other words what this verse is
telling us is that by and large the
world is at enmity with god and is the
enemy of god
and that's so interesting because that's
what your tendency then is your tendency
is worldly your tendency is worldly and
that has to be transformed and you
cannot do it by yourself
so martin if we look at this first
genesis 3 verse 15 it says i will put
enmity
between thee and the woman
and between thy seed and her seed and it
shall bruise thy head and thou shalt
bruise his heel
this enmity
that was promised here
is the first sermon ever preached
so we read here in signs of the times
this was the first gospel sermon ever
preached to fallen man
this promise was the star of hope
illuminating the dark and dismal future
of the race
adam gladly received the welcome
assurance of deliverance
and diligently instructed his children
in the way of the lord
this promise was presented in close
connection with the altar of sacrificial
offerings
the altar and the promise
stand side by side
and one casts clear beams of light upon
the other
showing that the justice of an offended
god could be appeased only by the death
of his beloved son
in the case of cain and abel we have a
type of two classes
that will exist in the world till the
close of time
and this type is worthy of close study
only two mindsets in the world the one
is the mindset of god
the other one is the mindset of satan
and unfortunately
we are trapped in a world
that largely has
embraced the mindset of satan
and also that means they've decided to
stand behind
the mindset of satan you have to make a
choice you cannot stand in between
between then you will be crushed that's
what martin luther said remember he said
make a choice
either stand behind the devil or stand
behind christ but to make peace between
the two is impossible you'll be crushed
in the process
so just to
elaborate on that here's a statement
from faith and works
there are the impressions that are going
forth all the time there's an atmosphere
that surrounds the human soul
and that atmosphere is a heavenly
atmosphere or a hellish atmosphere
there are but two distinct lines
either we are on christ's side of the
question
or on the enemy's side
if we are continually drawing rays of
divine light from glory angels of god
are around about us and there is an
atmosphere that surrounds the human soul
our very attitude
our very words witness genuine
conversion to all
who come within the sphere of our
influence
the spirit and the bride say come
and let him that heareth say come and
let him that is a thirst come
it's interesting martin
that he says come buy from me
yeah fight without money
come buy bread
come buy wine come buy the doctrine come
buy the bread of heaven
without price
but you have to choose to do that right
exactly that is so important because we
always think it's just haphazard
it's a decision you have to make a
decision and in order to be able to make
that decision you have to be drawn to
god
but who helps you who's doing the
drawing god is doing the drawing himself
and
he planted his cross
between divinity and humanity
and there it stands as the eternal link
between the two
that broken link
cost nothing less than the death of the
son of god
there are but two powers that control
the minds of men
the power of god
and the power of satan
christ is man's creator and redeemer
satan is man's enemy and destroyer
and he who has given himself to god will
build himself up for the glory of god in
body
soul
and spirit he who has given himself to
the control of satan tears himself down
and let's add anything
that surrounds him as well
this is a fact of history we're trapped
in this situation
but this clash of minds has to take
place and a decision has to be made
there is a quote from eternity past and
it says to seth
to him also there was born a son
and he called his name enos
then began men to call upon the name of
jehovah
the distinction between the two classes
became more and more mocked
an open profession of loyalty to god on
the part of one
contempt and disobedience on the part of
the other
so martin how long has this clash
been around
right from the beginning of the creation
and even before
so this started in heaven
now
how bewitching
is the mindset of satan
it's full of deceit that's why jesus
said be careful that you're not deceived
martin can you imagine
that the whole heaven was a stir
and that
a third of the angels
fell for the deception
initially
probably half the angels yeah
were vacillating between
the two
but that a third of the angel holy
beings
unfallen holy beings should decide for
the rebel
is amazing
and it's also interesting that sympathy
for the devil
was only abandoned and abolished out of
heaven
at the cross
when his true character was revealed
but how stubborn are we
even in the light of the cross
we will still
choose the rebels side
so here is this famous statement from
martin luther let the minds clash
but keep the fists down
unfortunately that applies to the
christians only
satan
has no misgivings he will not leave the
fists down
so martin when it comes to clash of
mines how many clashing ideologies are
there
i think
more than we've been down there's
hundreds thousands thousands thousands
right
so if we look at them in the light of
the bible
and just concentrate on that
isn't there a tremendous clash of minds
in the world with regard to the question
of origins
and how things came about
creation by design versus the theory of
evolution isn't that a clash of minds
one of the biggest
because like we've spoken in the
previous one there's so many fields
that base their
whole understanding
on
the evolutionary
thinking it touches every aspect of life
even the medical world right that's it
or particularly the medical world
so martin how many billions and billions
of dollars are being spent on an annual
basis
just furthering
the ideology and the mindset
of satan
with regard to this one point alone i
think you can wipe out poverty
on this earth if though that money
that's being spent there is spent to
look
after everybody on and how much how much
money does he spend and how much time
and how much effort does he spend on
advertising
his ideology it's uncountable it's
absolutely yeah every media production
that you see on nature
has his commercials in there textbooks
everything
all right
let's talk about the
authority and the law of god
the authority of god
versus the authority
of
another power
how much time and effort
goes into arguing on the authority of
god and the law of god
countless hours and then you must also
put it in perspective for how long has
this argument been going on all right
now churches that call themselves
christian churches
are they involved in this debate
the whole time so is there a clash of
minds when it comes to this yes
faith and works are you saved martin
are you saved by
faith
and receive
through faith the imputed and imparted
righteousness of christ or are you saved
by your works
by that imputed imparted righteousness
and then the outflow of that is works
but how much of a
conflict of minds is there on that how
much blood has flown on a clash of these
mindsets
unbelievable right
the word
the authority of the word
well you've got a clash of minds and the
origin of the word
you have a clash of minds on the origin
of the word you have a clash of minds on
the word itself
all right are there alternatives to the
word
that are out there
that are
in this clash
with the word
how many occult writers do we have do we
have the writings of blavatsky i think
the pendulum is a little bit
more to the
wrong side
yes on the amount of
thinkers and people that stand against
the word now you know it's interesting
martin the best-selling book
in the whole world
is no doubt the bible yeah
it is the one book that has a greater
distribution than any other book in the
world
and the writings of alice a bailey the
writings of blavatsky the writings of
albert pike
have a much smaller
distribution than the bible
but by those that have them
they are actually read
whereas the bible stands on many
bookshelves and he's never read
right yeah that's so true isn't it isn't
that a sad state of affairs
but once you you get to know these two
mindsets then it is obvious that there's
a clash of minds
a tremendous clash of minds
and with all the lies that have been
introduced through the theory of
evolution
through all of the other issues
doubt is constantly cast upon
this book
this good book lying here that is the
main point
i think of this clash is to just get the
that authority of that book
a little bit down and if you think of
the effort that he put in
to discredit the very first sentence in
the beginning god
created
if you can discredit the first line
then basically he has discredited the
whole book right
this is an amazing
clash
and then of course when we get a little
bit closer to home
then you have
some additional information in the
spirit of prophecy
and even within the ranks of those that
claim to be people of the book
is there a clash of minds when it comes
to the spirit of prophecy
even in the local churches
full of it isn't that a sad state of
affairs
unfortunately
this clash of minds will probably stay
with us till
jesus comes to fetch us all right now if
you go to the book of revelation it says
the testimony of jesus
is the spirit of prophecy
so if you really believe that
then
whose testimony are you actually
doubting
jesus's testimony that's a very serious
issue right
now isn't he also called the word yes
and man does not live by bread alone but
by every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of of the lord right
so are you questioning
virtually everything that jesus ever
said
if you question the bible and the spirit
of prophecy you are treading on that
water
yes
all right
let's have a look at a few other issues
how do you control the minds of men
this becomes an important issue when it
comes to a clash of mind isn't it
exactly
all right so we have a clash between
coercion and freedom of conscience
how vehement
is this clash becoming in the days that
we are living in
well i think if you look back the past
two years and what's currently going on
you can see there's a big shift in how
they control
what you have you think of all right so
there are two tactics also involved it's
not only a clash of minds
it's also two tactics as to
bring the one or the other mindset to
your attention right
the one is
a drawing power
based on
love it finds its culmination in a cross
and the cross is the guarantee
that god has granted humanity freedom of
choice and freedom of conscience
because if he were a coercive god
he could have prevented the fall by
enforcing his mindset
this is the beauty of god he never
forces his mindset if i be lifted up
i will force all people to me does he
say that no
no
if i be lifted up i will
draw all people to me
whereas the other mindset is
i will force you yes i will you will do
as i say implement laws and all of this
but you will do as we say can this clash
of minds even enter the very ranks of
god's people
unfortunately yes right
let's take a little bit more
naturalistic view
on the issue of health reform
is there a clash of minds there's a big
clash of minds in the world on that one
and at which level
top
every level there's no level top to
bottom right everybody no matter whether
you go into a the tiniest little local
church or whether you go up to the very
top
you're going to have a clash of minds
let's not even speak about the godhead
is there a clash of minds
you know some people think that they
fully understand how god works and how
he operates and they create parameters
and god better stay within those
parameters or else they get a soapbox
and they stand on that thing and they
won't move that's
that's their gospel now doesn't god
transcend our human
capacity so so much is
unthinkable it's unthinkable
unfathomable
now martin
this is a very interesting
little video
and it's uh
it's the thought processes of yuval
harare from the hebrew university is a
very very prominent man today
very popular in ted talks very popular
in many many places in the world and of
course one of the advisors to klaus
schwab yeah the world economic forum the
world economic forum and the way in
which they think and the way in which
they operate i find fascinating
let's just look what he has to say
but some gov governments and
corporations for the first time in
history have the power to basically hack
human beings there is a lot of talk
about hacking computers hacking
smartphones hacking bank accounts but
the big story of our era is the ability
to hack human beings and by this i mean
that if you have enough data and you
have enough computing power you can
understand people better than they
understand themselves and then you can
manipulate them in ways which were
previously impossible
and
in such a situation the old democratic
system
stop functioning
we need to reinvent democracy for this
new era
in which humans are now hackable animals
you know the whole idea that humans have
you know this they they have this soul
or spirit and they have free will and
nobody knows what's happening inside me
so whatever i choose whether in the
election or whether in the supermarket
this is my free will that's over
we need to come to terms with the fact
that you know what again this is where
philosophy meets computer science and
biology
no matter what you think ultimately is
the truth of the universe you have to
realize that practically today we have
the technology to hack human beings on a
massive scale and this means you need we
need to reinvent democracy
martin are you
that ready to give up your freedom of
choice
i definitely not because
jesus died for my freedom of choice so
what was the price of your freedom of
choice the death of the son of god right
can you imagine that
now there are people that think that
your freedom of choice
can just be
rode rough shot over
it's interesting
that when they are planning this digital
currency
the digital currency won't be just a
digital number that you can use at your
will apparently martin
it will be
programmed
so that you can only choose what you are
permitted to buy exactly it's like when
they say you will own nothing and you'll
be happy
the happiness will be
linked to what they decide is happiness
for you yes you'll get a quota you may
buy so much of this per month thereafter
sorry your money won't be able to buy
that anymore your freedom of choice will
be taken away
now the question of course then is
who supplants your freedom of choice
well the devil's agents because the
mindset of the enemy
is to take away your free will
yes the enemy uses coercive tactics he's
always used them
he's always used force you do it my way
or i'll kill you
isn't that what cain did to abel that's
it and that mindset has been there from
the beginning
and this is another
important aspect of a clash of minds
god wants us to have the mindset of god
but he will never force us
and if you are lost it will be by your
own choice because once you've thought
it through
there is no more logical system than you
will find in the scriptures
exactly you tell me one of the ten
commandments martin that is irrelevant
not one
and if you really put it
that way
if you
think about it
which one of the ten commandments is not
for your benefit
all of them are all of them are and for
everyone else exactly
and what was in also interesting what he
said is
that
they can manipulate your mind
so
how many people will they manipulate
in thinking that the way that they want
to introduce this freedom is the best
way for you
they're going to be
manipulating your mind and they're busy
with it already
now the interesting thing martin
if you are totally without god
you might be totally against having your
mind manipulated
but you will be caught on so many levels
you won't even know what's happened to
you that's exactly what i was trying to
say
if you're not grounded in the word and
what what the truth is or what's reality
then unfortunately they will
manipulate your mind
samadhin in order to understand this
clash of minds
we have to go all the way back in
history right
and to study history
and to put it into perspective
is not conspiracy theory no it is
biblical prophecy
and biblical history
here is a statement from testimonies for
the church volume 8 page 307
and it says there's a study of history
that is not to be condemned sacred
history was one of the studies in the
school of the prophets
in the record of his dealings with the
nations were traced the footsteps of
jehovah so today
we are to consider the dealings of god
with the nations of the earth
we are to see in history the fulfillment
of prophecy
to study the workings of providence in
the great reformatory movements and to
understand the progress of events in the
marshalling of the nations for the final
conflict of the great controversy
so we can find clues
as to what's happening in the world
today
in past history right
what is that saying
if you don't learn out of history you
are doomed or prone to repeat it
absolutely that's exactly what will
happen so we need to study sacred
history
we need to understand how god dealt with
the nations in the past why it was
sometimes necessary to eradicate entire
nations
in order for
the decision capacity
to continue to the next generation
so if god went so far as to eliminate
a group
or a nation
than it was for the benefit of posterity
signs of the times
cain represents those who carry out the
principles and works of satan
by worshiping god in a way of their own
choosing
like the leader whom they follow they
are willing to render partial obedience
but not entire submission to god
the cain claus of worshippers includes
by far the largest number
for every false religion that has been
invented has been based on the cain
principle
that man can depend upon his own merits
and righteousness for salvation
martin there's the cain principle
and by far
the greatest number
adheres to the cain principle isn't that
a sad situation very sad and it's
important if you might not even know
that you're on the cane side if you
don't read that book
you're right
so let's look at this again genesis
chapter 4 verse 15
and the lord said unto him therefore
whosoever slayeth cain vengeance shall
be taken on him sevenfold and the lord
set a mark upon cain list any finding
him should kill him
it's a very interesting statement
and we read it in genesis chapter 4.
that's just after the fall of genesis
chapter 3
right now what is this mark well
it is a flag a beacon a monument a omen
a prodigy a evidence a mark a miracle a
sign a token
it's the same word
that is used for the sabbath
as a sign between god and man
so there's a mark of cain
and there is a mark of god yeah right so
there's a sign of cain if you want to
use the other word and a sign
of god
now what does the sign stand for it
stands for authority
who has authority
i give you my sabbaths as a sign between
you and me that i am the god
that sanctifies you
that's maybe the primary
clash
is authority authority whose authority
do you submit to who do you believe
i mean the very first words of the
serpent word did god really say
right
questioning what god has said
questioning the mindset of god in
reality
and then going
directly against the mindset no god
didn't mean that
it's actually like this
exodus 31 13 speak thou also unto the
children of israel saying verily my
sabbath ye shall keep for it is a sign
it's that same word between me and you
throughout your generations that you may
know that i am the lord that does
sanctify you
where does my strength come from from
god
who has authority in my life
well that depends on your choice
and through your works you can start
judging
as to which side you chose right
all right so there are two marks in the
world there's the mark of cain
and there's the mark of god
now the mark of god is not a physical
mark
therefore neither is the mark of cain
a physical mark
it is a sign of authority now how much
authority did god actually grant cain
well let's read it again
so cain said
well he's the vagabond what's going to
happen now if they find him they're
going to slay him
so god did something amazing
knowing that this person was a child of
disobedience a rebel against god's cause
a hater of the mindset of god to the
point of killing anyone
with a contrary mindset
god says to him
therefore whosoever slayeth cain
vengeance shall be taken on him
sevenfold
and the lord set a mark upon cain lest
any finding him should kill him
all right now if the mark of god is the
sign of god's
because the sabbath has the seal of god
he's the creator of heaven and earth
right therefore he commanded you
therefore he gave
cain authority
to
avenge himself sevenfold
in other words he had the power
to give a punishment sevenfold greater
than anything that he's done unto him
so you know some people are put in jail
for small misdemeanors
for very very long time
and others get away with murder
[Music]
all right so he gave cain authority
and cain knew his wife and she conceived
and bear enoch
and he builded the city and called the
name of the city after the name of his
son enoch
it's very important that we understand
that this is not the enoch that walked
with god
this is the enoch
son of cain
several generations before the enoch
that walked with god
and unto enoch was born
irat
and he wrote beget me
and me
beget methuselah and methuselah begat
lamech
so here are a few generations
and you get to the generation of lamech
and lamech took unto him two wives
the name of the one was ada
and the name of the other was zilla
two things happen dear martin
the first is they built a city
that's against what god wanted god
didn't want you to live in cities
the second is
that after just a few generations
obviously
the issues of lust took over
and lamech took for himself two wives
right the one was ada and the other one
was zilla
and lamech said unto his wives ada and
zillah hear my voice ye wives of lamech
hearken unto my speech for i have slain
a man to my wounding and a young man to
my heart
if cain shall be avenged sevenfold truly
lamech
seventy and sevenfold
that's very interesting
what happens here we have a further
apostasy he takes
two wives
god only created one wife for adam
not two
right
so the other thing that happens is that
his power
to
wield his authority
increases from sevenfold
to according to the king james 70 and
seven fault let's just go to the geneva
bible which is the first
real protestant bible
and eats it 70 times sevenfold so that's
another way of translating it
that's very interesting 70 times 7. that
brings up various issues
there's a prophecy
70 times 7
we read it in the book of daniel right
how often did jesus say do you have to
forgive the same 70 times 7 okay but
this one doesn't forgive
no he doesn't forgive he punishes he
punishes 70 times seven times right
so it's two different mindsets
one of love
and forgiveness
without sacrificing justice
and the other one is
brutality in enforcing
their so-called justice
so these people
cain
and his posterity became the rulers of
the children
of disobedience and they wielded the
mark of cain the mark of authority
all right
let's go to
the occult writings
and let's see what morals and dogma by
albert pike had to say on this issue
and he's talking about
masonry which is so highly esteemed in
the world today
and many of or most if not all of the
top leaders in the world belong to this
fraternity right
enoch his name signifies in hebrew
initiate or initiate tor
the legend of the columns of granite and
brass or bronze erected by him is
probably symbolic
that of bronze which survived the flood
is supposed to symbolize the mysteries
of which masonry is the legitimate
successor
from the earliest times the custodians
and depository of the great
philosophical and religious truths
unknown to the world at large
and handed down from age to age by an
unbroken current of tradition embodied
in symbols emblems and allegories
sir martin
to whom do they trace their symbols and
allegories and traditions and religion
too not the enoch that walked with god
well we'll have to find out which enoch
is it all right
we'll have to find out but it's to enoch
right
all right enoch son of jared descended
from adam via the lane of seth
seventh generation from adam according
to usher enoch would thus have been born
in
bc
okay
pike's book
is dated masonically and by christian
reckoning
and the dates given are five six eight
zero
am which stands for ano mundi or year of
the world
and it also gives the date
1871 for morals and dogma
so in other words morals and dogma was
written in 1871 a.d
or
5680 ano munda from the year of the
world
now what does that date back to let's
find out so if we subtract the one from
the other
then we get to bc
in bc80 reckoning to
3809 bc
all right so the masonic calendar
according to albert pike started in 3809
bc
that's 427 years before enoch that
walked with god
so who do they trace their lineage to to
enoch that walked with god or enoch son
of cain son of gain
the custodian and depository of the
masonic truths could thus not have been
this enoch but must have been enoch son
of cain couldn't have been the good
enoch right no
so they have traced their origin back to
rebellion
right here's another quote not from
morals and dogma now but from
blavatsky's writing the secret doctrine
volume one
remember that albert pike says their
religion is secret
right once that the key to genesis is in
our hands
it is the scientific and symbolical
kabbalah which unveils the secret so
what is this great secret martin
it's that the great serpent of the
garden of eden and the lord god are
identical and so are jehovah and cain
one
so in other words they have deified cain
who has a mark
a mark of authority
and they have rejected
god
jehovah
who has a mark
of authority therefore from the very
beginning the mark of jehovah
which is
the sabbath as a symbol of his authority
must have been rejected by cain right
that cain who is referred to in theology
as the murderer and the liar to god
jehovah tempts the king of israel to
number the people and satan tempts him
to do the same in another place jehovah
turns into the fiery serpents to bite
those
he is displeased with and jehovah
informs the brazen serpent that heals
them
these shortened seemingly contradictory
statements in the old testament
contradictory because the two powers are
separated instead of being regarded as
the two faces of one and the same are
the secret doctrine
good and evil
co-joined
that is their doctrine yin yang
they of course distort the facts here
where the bible says in one place that
jehovah tempted david to number the
people and the other place it says satan
tempted it you must understand it
from the mindset that whatever god
permits that's it
is also regarded as his will
now why would god permit something that
is negative and has negative
consequences so that the true can live
itself out
yes and because he honors your freedom
of choice
you will not go against your freedom of
choice but your freedom of choice has
consequences
so in other words their god
is cain
and the god of cain
is satan satan
now let's continue this saga and it came
to pass when men began to multiply on
the face of the earth and daughters were
born unto them
that the sons of god saw that the
daughters of men that they were fair
and they took them wives of all which
they chose
so martin from the beginning there were
two classes
those that were the sons of god
they were from the line of seth yes and
those that were from the line of cain
through enoch and eventually to lamech
and continuing down to the present day
those two mindsets have been clashing
and then it comes to the point where it
gets so bad that the lord says my spirit
shall not always strive with man for
that he also is flesh yet his days shall
be a hundred and twenty years
and there were giants in the earth in
those days and also after that when the
sons of god came in unto the daughters
of men
and they bear children to them the same
became mighty men which were of old men
of renown
now this verse is so distorted in this
modern world of ours there's a clash of
minds on this verse
clash of minds even within the ranks of
those who supposedly stand for the bible
right
spirit of prophecy makes it very clear
it says that it was the descendants of
seth that lived in the mountains and
that were
farmers and lived on the land
came into contact with
the
posterity of cain
in the cities yes
they probably met in a mall
and there they saw eventually that the
daughters of
men the line of cane
were flashy
they were desirable
but now i assumed their dresses were
somewhat shorter than those that were
of the line of sin
and i think there were a couple of bells
and whistles around them
that
made them very attractive and maybe you
know the neckline was down to the navel
who knows exactly what the case was but
nevertheless
they couldn't resist them some of them
and then children were born and these
became men of renown
in other words they became fighters and
enemies of god
people who were
forceful and could enforce their will
organizing protests and
putting out wars or organizing wars
correct and then eventually it got so
bad that god saw that the wickedness of
man was great in the earth and that
every imagination of the thoughts of his
heart was only evil continually and it
repented the lord that he had made man
on the earth and it grieved him at his
heart
in other words he allowed this mindset
to take its course until it got to the
point that if he hadn't intervened
no flesh could be saved
so those who lived in the days of noah
and abraham
this is a very interesting quote by the
way from early writings
resembled the angels in form comeliness
and strength
but every succeeding generation have
been growing weaker and more subject to
disease and their life has been of
shorter duration
satan has been learning how to annoy and
in feeble the race
someone all the way down even past the
flood to the time of abraham
men were of great stature resembling
angels
it's interesting if you come to think of
it
when the three men came and one was
jesus and and the other two to abram and
they walked to go and destroy
sodom and gomorrah they were angels
but they were
resembling men because they there wasn't
a physical that's much of a difference
yes so these men were men of renown they
were of great stature
they were compared to to us who have
become shrimps because of degeneration
they were like giants
and some
generations still had this
giant gene in them even up to the time
of david
and then it basically disappeared from
all of humanity
so we mustn't misunderstand these verses
when we read them in the bible
so for example if you read genesis 6 2
and 4 in the common english bible it
says the divine beings saw how beautiful
these human women were so they married
the ones they chose
and those days giants lived on the earth
and also afterwards when divine beings
and human daughters had sexual relations
and gave birth to children that is just
as much nonsense as you can conjure up
it's sickening yes and the good news
bible doesn't improve on it either some
of the heavenly beings saw that
these young women were beautiful so they
took the ones they liked in those days
and even later there were giants on the
earth who were descendants of human
women and heavenly beings
martin this is a total distortion of
scripture
so just another point
is it important as to which bible we use
definitely and this pulls through even
to in different languages in our
afrikaans bibles the old translation
still has it the same as the king james
the newer ones we did the same as this
in any case it's not in harmony with the
rest of the bible because jesus clearly
stated that angels do not propagate
so you know this is this kind of
distortion that you can get and a
distortion of history now you see look
at this distortion now they
first distort the enoch that this whole
occult come from
then they distort that these giants were
actually hybrids from
angels and humans it's absolutely
pathetic this war is raging down here
amongst humanity
no angel has the capacity to reproduce
it is a new order of being
god-created man
male
and female and it's a very simple
statement of fact those that were in
harmony with god
eventually intermingled with those that
were not in harmony with god and the
result is
what happened
wickedness spread throughout all of
humanity martin we are at that point yes
we are at that same point where god will
have to destroy humanity again
and again it will be their own choosing
in other words only those with the
mindset
that will create harmony for all
eternity
will be able to partake
in eternity yes and there's another
thing some people might say yes but in
jude it says the angels left its first
estate
that means not that they changed their
form to human
it means that they sinned and left
heaven yes they were holy beings and now
they sinned and they were fallen correct
so let's read this statement in the
spirit of prophecy just to get a better
perspective here
for some time the two classes the
descendants of cain and the descendants
of seth
remained separate
the race of canes spreading from the
place of their first settlement
dispersed over the plains and valleys
where the children of seth had dwelt and
the latter in order to escape from their
contaminating influence withdrew to the
mountains and there made their homes so
long as this separation continued
they maintained the worship of god in
its purity
but in the lapse of time they ventured
little by little to mingle with the
inhabitants of the valleys
this association was productive of the
worst results
the sons of god saw that the daughters
of men
that they were fair and the children of
seth attracted by the beauty of the
daughters of cain's descendants
displeased the lord by intermarrying
with them
many of the worshippers of god were
beguiled into sin
by the alluments that were now
constantly before them and they lost
their peculiar holy character
mingling with the depraved they became
like them in spirit and deeds
the restrictions of the seventh
commandment were disregarded and they
took them wives of all they chose
the children of seth went in the way of
cain
quoting jude 11
they fixed their minds on worldly
prosperity and enjoyment
and neglected the commandment of god
men did not like to retain god in their
knowledge they became vain in their
imagination and their foolish hearts
were darkened quoting romans 1 21
therefore god gave them over to a mind
void of judgment verse 28
sin spread abroad in the earth like a
deadly leprosy here again when god gave
them over
to a mind void of judgment it was god's
permissive will
why would god permit that
because he has to let it show what it
means and what happens if you don't
choose his mind ah
it's another proof
that god does not coerce that he grants
freedom of choice
but satan does not and while reading
this we can see that we are at this
point in history again
now if we go back into ancient history
and we go into the syrian history and
the babylonian history
there
is this interesting story of the god
marduk
and
the sign of anu
which is the sword and the trident
so the trident is this three-pronged
thing over here and the sword is the
symbol of authority correct
and if you look carefully on the hem at
the bottom here
you will see a sign
which is known as the sign of anu
so anu
gave
cain
a sign
so
marduk in actual fact represents
kane
or later
or later lamech or whoever the
successive ruler is
and he has authority
over this terrible creature over here
who are the children of disobedience
all right so the children of
disobedience in other words this earth
was to be under the rule of cain
and the punishments were actually quite
harsh
it's interesting you know martin my
my wife
was teaching at a school
with disadvantaged children and they
came from terrible backgrounds
and she was at a loss at one stage as to
how to deal with their disobedience
because she was trying to be kind and
christian and
they were making a complete joke of it
right
so one day
she decided that this was not working
in her class
and so she said all right we're going to
do something new
i will not set the rules anymore
i'm going to put you in charge
so now
you who are all disobedient you make the
rules
so if somebody does this that or the
other what will be the punishment
according to you
and she wrote the rules down
on the board
and she said to them
now is that what you choose are these
the rules that you want and these roots
were so harsh
ten times worse than what she would have
done right seventy times seven seventy
times seven and you know what they
enforced them
it was the only way to control the class
and this is exactly
what god did
god said you won't listen to me you are
children of rebellion i'll put the
children of rebellion in charge of the
children of rebellion and that will sort
out the problem
you want to do this or the other this is
going to be the consequence
and
that's how it worked for the children of
disobedience unless of course you were
an insider and got away with murder
right
which is the case even till today yes
so this is what happened so basically
the story of maduk who got his power
from the god anu
is the story of cain
who received the mark of authority
now what was the seal of authority
well it was always symbolized as
the star which became the star of ishta
or the sign of shamash
or it's called the solar wield and these
ancient kings always had the sign of
their authority
and here you can see that it is
basically two crosses or two stars
superimposed the one with the wavy lines
and the other with non-wavy lines
now the wavy lines represent the female
form and the other one the masculine
form
so it is also like a yin yang male
female androgenic baphomet the god of
satanism
is androgenic it's both male and female
here is the goddess ishta
and here is the star of her authority so
whether it is in the female form
or whether it is in the mail form it's
irrelevant it's a yin-yang system
so that is the star of their authority
now if we go in history back into
history
then there are some very interesting
parallels
sahih for example is a assyrian relief
and there you have the sirian king and
here are some vassals
underlings that are paying in homage now
it's very interesting
that
this particular black obelix of
chalmunisa iii
shows who this vassal is who is bowing
down over there
and it says it is yehu
so this is incredible
so here was this king and notice his
headgear
and
he had the authority
and any other state
had to be subject to that authority
and yehu
represented the northern tribes of
israel
and he was obviously subject to
shamanism
so there was this king who yielded the
mark of cain
the mark of authority
and yehu was submissive to him
but he was free
to be a ruler in his own country
by permission
of charmaneser
and in order to demonstrate that freedom
he had a particular little hat on
which was called the phrygian hat and
here you can see
these bringing gifts and they all have
the same little hat on it isn't that
interesting
this is a
where occultism gets this
symbolism from
so in other words
jehu
was only allowed to rule if he was
subject would bow down to shalmaneser
yes with the mark with the mark now is
it possible martin that there is a power
today
that represents the sun god
and has the mark of cain or the power of
shamas as it at his fingertips and the
sign of anu and any other ruler
may rule in freedom as a free man
if he bows down to this power definitely
as a sovereign nation but you're not so
sovereign you're still under the
authority of
now martin if this man jehu was an
israelite
shouldn't he have had another mindset
shouldn't his mindset that you shall not
bow down to anyone
all right let's take it to our modern
times here's the god mitra and he has
that same
hat
in other words what this mindset says is
you have freedom
provided
you bow down to my authority that's it
as long as you abide by
their rules your freedom all right
so here's the the symbol of the power of
the state the united states
senate
and it has as its symbol the phrygian
hat
now this is a very
naughty little question here
who wore that at was it jehu or was it
chalmanisa jehu
who was subject to whom jay was subject
to salman izza martin is the senate
therefore subject to somebody else
because he's wearing the phrygian
he has to be so he's a free ruler
but he must get his authority to rule
from another power
so who's the salmanesa that gives the
united states senate the power to make
laws
is that a question we could ask i think
it's a very important question all right
now how do they enforce their authority
well here is the united states
department of the army
and
what do we have there martin
once again the frigenet
and what is above them
the serpent
ah
now who wields the power of the serpent
on his behalf on this earth that's a
question we'll just leave hanging right
so martin let's just go to rome
here is the church of the gezu
giza del gezu which is the
mother church of the society of jesus
says jesuit the jesuits
and if you enter into that church you
will see here this symbol of the woman
who has the lightning bolt in her hand
and she represents of course the church
of rome
she has the cross in her hand
and she has here
martin luther and calvin
falling
and being overwhelmed by her power
and then you have an angel over here
tearing apart the writings of martin
luther which is basically the bible
so martin this is also the power that
claims to have the two swords
the sword the secular sword of the state
in other words she wields power over the
state
and the sword of the spirit
interesting right so that's the
religious part as well now what is
fascinating martin if you look at the
vatican square
with the obelisk
which is obviously of pagan origin
in the center you have the largest sign
of anu in the world
right there
where you have
the two
crosses over each other so he's he's
actually advertising to the world
that he
has the mark of cain that's it the sign
of authority
and even the united states of america
even the
powerful military
has the phrygian cap which means he's
subservient
let's look at this temple of freemasonry
which is of the supreme council and it
is in washington
so freemasonry when you enter it has the
sign of anu right there as well
as was worn by shamash and maduk
so they have the mark of cain
the authority to rule over the children
of disobedience just like that class
of my wife
had to make the rules to contain the
disobedience of the disobedient in
actual fact the ring leaders of
disobedience became the enforcers
and that's exactly what god did
let's go to another place here you go to
the supreme court
of the united states of america and
everywhere you go you have the sign of
anu
that means the sign of authority to
enforce punishments
even seventy times sevenfold
whereas god asks you to forgive seventy
times seven times they enforce their
punishment
70 times seven times
and masonry
and government have always been aligned
and you can check it out this is not a
conspiracy this happens to be a fact
and the religious world
is also
in cahoots with this system
here you have a picture of billy graham
with
hoover who was of course a high mason he
was also a shriner freemason
and the liaison with the papacy
they are all interconnected this is not
a conspiracy
here you have
norman vincent peale
who is basically the protestant father
of people like robert schuller
and even donald trump yes he's a
spiritual advisor
and here he is a 33 degree freemason and
we read what morals and dogma
and blavatsky
said about the real rulers
harry truman so whether you are on the
political side whether you are in the
modern religious side martin
are you following the mark of cain
or are you following the mark of god i
want to follow the mark of god
now
isn't it made manifest that you are
following the mark of god
by obedience to all of his commandments
that's it
is the religious world today obedient to
all of god's commandments or are they
obedient to the successor of shalmunesa
and the king of babylon that's it they
go to the sign of anuk
isn't it interesting that even the jews
netanyahu thank the pope for jewish
exoneration
when it comes to
the death of jesus yeah so who has the
authority to do this
the pope has the authority martin does
he wield the sign of anu
does he bear the mark of cain
simon the catholic church says that
sunday is our mark of authority the
church is above the bible and this
transference of sabbath observance is
proof of that fact
catholic record september the 1st 1923
we have two authorities
just as in the ancient world you had the
authority of cain
and you had those that adhered to the
authority of god unfortunately they
started to intermingle
and the result is what we have in the
world today
the roman catholic search says
that you must keep sunday pope john paul
ii said a person who violates the
sanctity of sunday is to be punished as
a heretic
but what was the punishment for a
heretic
torture and death
so who wields that kind of authority to
say that
someone who disobeys their law which is
contrary to god's law
cain had that authority
cain had that authority and they wield
that authority today
all right and they have given it to
their vassals who wear the phrygian cap
which is the symbol of the french
revolution which is the symbol of
freemasonry which is a symbol of
this whole conflict this whole clash of
minds from the beginning
catholic church and trade unions form
holy alliance to enforce sunday
observance now more so than ever this
started already in the days of benedict
but we know that pope francis has had
meetings with the greatest trade unions
of all times
for the exact same purpose
martin are they at war
with the authority of god
is there a clash of minds
so if you go down into the shrine of
that 33 degree freemason temple in
washington you come to a room which is
called the albert pike room
this man who says that lucifer is the
true son of god
has
so much
veneration
and yet the world accepts it
and thinks that it is the marvelous
thing if you go to the queens and the
kings of the world
and the princes of the world aren't they
all part of this system
so are they wielding the mark of cain
or are they subservient to the mark of
god they wielding the mark of cain
and their motto is order ab cow
order out of chaos
and we've seen our fair share of chaos
so the order even if there's chaos at
this stage they will get to that point
all right what is their ultimate
objective
to rid the world of anyone who is
subservient to god yes
and they will use chaos in order to
create their order right anyone who goes
against them their authority
here's an interesting article from the
12th of march 2022 how ukraine
has become the crucible of the new
world order
russia's invasion of ukraine has been
described by politicians and
commentators as a watershed moment
in modern history a turning point
comparable in importance to 9 11 attack
in the u.s in 2001
the fall of the berlin wall in 1989 and
even the assassination of john f kennedy
in 1963.
whether this pretentious view of the war
turns out to be justified only time and
future historians will tell but there is
no doubt
that in the violent
tumultuous days of the 24th of february
the established international order has
been shaken in some respects upended in
extraordinary unexpected and often
unwelcome ways ukraine a country at the
crossroads of europe and asia
that is little known and often ignored
has become overnight the crucible of a
new world order a catalyst and trigger
for radical upheaval
does that sound like it fits the gender
mod order out of chaos now martin we've
had our share of chaos over the last two
years
has there been a clash of minds as to
who should adhere to whose rulings oh
definitely
has there been some order that has come
out of this chaos that we had
yes there are new rules
now martin are those rules
in harmony
with the way god would do things
allowing freedom of conscience to take
its course or are they draconian
they are draconian
but according to the people that made
them they're for your own good
ah so who decides my own good
they do they do they do they will decide
what i need what i can shop what i
cannot shop how i shall conduct myself
and if i don't 70 times seven
is the punishment right
they will trample me with horses if i do
not comply
is that the mark of cain or is that the
mark of god okay is that the mindset of
god or is it the mindset of cain that's
a mindset of cain
definitely
god even permitted cain to punish seven
times
but lamech said no i'll do it seventy
times seven times
isn't that interesting
all right so we're heading for the close
of the great controversy the final clash
of mines
god's word has given warning of the
impending danger
let this be unheeded and the protestant
world will learn what the purposes of
rome really are
only when it is too late to escape the
snare
she silently growing into power
her doctrines are exerting their
influence in the legislative halls
in the churches and in the hearts of men
she is piling up her lofty and massive
structures in the secret recesses of
which her former persecutions
will be repeated
stealthily and unsuspectedly she is
strengthening her forces to further our
own ends and when the time shall come
for her to strike
all that she desires is vantage ground
and this is already being given her
we shall soon see and shall feel what
the purpose of the roman element is
whoever shall believe and obey the word
of god will thereby incur reproach and
persecution
are we heading for a clash of minds
i don't think we're heading we're
already there we're in a clash of mine
already in a glacier is it important
that we get the message out
is it important that people are warned
as to what the consequences will be if
we follow this mindset
martin
philippians 2 verse 5
let this mind be in you
which was also
in christ jesus
may all
be willing
to stand for
this message this choice
between two mindsets
let us work together
to bring the message of salvation and
the final message of warning to the
world
so that people can make informed choices
let's pray
heavenly father
there is indeed a clash of minds
and this clash of minds will eventually
culminate
in the greatest persecution that this
world has ever seen
but you have promised
a thousand may fall at your side ten
thousand at your right hand and it shall
not come near you
help us to make the right choice
and to look at the cross
the guarantee
that the one who makes the rules of
heaven
is the compassionate god who is prepared
to die
for those who have transgressed his laws
give us the courage to stand for
righteousness and truth in this time
that we are living in is my prayer in
jesus name amen
[Music]
you